y como lo venimos hablando pues estamos
allá en nuestra sección de economía para
hablar de todas las opciones cómo están
reaccionando los mercados mundiales ante
toda esta situación hay preocupación hay
incertidumbre en absolutamente todo el
mundo todos los países toda la comunidad
internacional que tiene los ojos puestos
ahorita mismo en ucrania y rusia
dependiendo de todas las decisiones
también que tome el presidente ruso
vladimir putin en todo esto porque
digamos que él fue el causante de todo
lo que está ocurriendo en este momento y
ya está entonces listo jorge hurtado
jorge hablamos por supuesto de los
mercados cómo están reaccionando primero
a esta situación en ucraniano y el
petróleo fue el primero que reaccionó
así pero comentando te un poco el
panorama general de las acciones en el
mundo hubo una gran salida o una gran
venta masiva por así decirlo las
acciones mundiales se desplomaron tras
la acción militar rusa en ucrania
mientras washington y europa prometen
más sanciones a moscú que pueden hacer
tambalear incluso la economía mundial
los índices de referencia del mercado en
europa y en cayeron hasta un 4% según
analistas los mercados financieros se
encuentran en una huida hacia la
seguridad y puede que tengan que valorar
un crecimiento más lento debido a los
altos costos de la energía que bueno ya
están en tendencia alcista y con esto
pues aumentarán muchísimo más el índice
japonés cerró en menos 1 81% y el hang
seng de hong kong cayó un -3 77 por
ciento a pocos minutos de su cierre los
futuros europeos perdieron un 3.5 por
ciento la bolsa de parís abrió con
fuertes pérdidas tras el ataque militar
de rusia contra ucrania y el cac-40
llegó a caer hasta un 4 26 por ciento en
los primeros minutos de la sesión la
bolsa española se desplomó un 4,31 por
ciento tras el ataque la bolsa de rusia
es la que ha sufrido una de las mayores
pérdidas a su apertura cayó más de un
45% raúl veamos qué opinan los analistas
de mercados de este comportamiento atrás
el conflicto o el aumento de las
tensiones en europa del este
artista vemos la clásica reacción a esto
el precio del oro aumenta las deudas de
los estados aumentan y por desgracia el
petróleo y el gas también las bolsas se
han desplomado pero intentan recuperarse
ya que vemos un factor positivo todavía
en este desastre omicron está
disminuyendo esto significa que la
economía global puede volver a respirar
espero que la invasión rusa no destruya
las cadenas de suministro y el
sentimiento de modo que cause daños pero
hay que mantenerse unidos y me parece
muy importante tener siempre un ojo
puesto en china a los chinos no les
interesa una economía mundial débil y
les gustaría seguir haciendo negocios
con eeuu y europa un muy hago para ese
tema ahora sí jorge como adelantaba al
principio hablemos de cuál es la
situación actual del petróleo así que
bueno el índice de referencia brent
superó por primera vez los 100 dólares
esto no sucedía de 2014 la escalada en
europa del este- genera un movimiento
alcista en este mercado que ya venía
presionado de finales del año pasado
esto porque el suministro de petróleo en
todo el mundo no logra seguir el ritmo
de la recuperación acción post pandemia
también sucede en un contexto en que la
coalición de países exportadores de
petróleo opep tienen dificultades para
restablecer la producción esta semana la
firma hippie morgan chase aseguró que es
probable que los precios del petróleo se
sitúen en una media de 110 dólares en el
segundo trimestre el gobierno de joe
biden incluso estudia la posibilidad de
volver a recurrir a su suministro de
energía de emergencia perdón de petróleo
en coordinación con sus aliados para
contrarrestar el aumento de los precios
provocados por las medidas de rusia
contra ucrania a finales del año pasado
se recurrió a estas reservas para
liberar la atención de los altos precios
de combustible a nivel mundial que tiene
su incidencia en los altos niveles de
inflación a parte del petróleo y gas
rusia es también un gran productor de
aluminio y trigo así como ucrania otra
de las consecuencias el aumento del
precio de múltiples materias primas que
contribuirá al repunte de la inflación
hasta el nivel más alto en décadas según
expertos el trigo rompe un nuevo récord
en europa y llegó a los 344 euros por
tonelada debido a la invasión de ucrania
por la casa blanca y europa anunciaron
sanciones para algunos bancos la deuda
soberana y élites rusas jorge y tras la
primera ronda de sanciones contra rusia
ya se anunciaron nuevas medidas así es
los líderes de la unión europea han
estado anunciando y también que se
reunirán para discutir de emergencia la
reacción a esta escalada en contra de
ucrania así lo confirmo ursula von der
leyen presidente de la comisión europea
la funcionaria adelantó que las nuevas
sanciones apuntaron a sectores
estratégicos de la economía rusa
bloqueando su acceso a tecnologías y
mercados claves contra la ley en
prometió que el bloque debilitar a la
base económica de rusia y su capacidad
de modernización otra de las medidas que
anunció es que detendrán el acceso de
los bancos rusos al mercado financiero
europeo el miércoles la unión europea
aprobó una primera ronda de sanciones
que incluye a políticos rusos una lista
negra y el freno al comercio entre la
unión europea y dos regiones
separatistas del este de ucrania cuya
independencia fue reconocida por rusia
este sería el paquete de sanciones más
duro que jamás se haya aplicado según
dijo el jefe de la política exterior del
josep borrell por el agregó que este es
uno de los momentos más oscuros para
europa del final de la segunda guerra
mundial el primer ministro del reino
unido por johnson prometió también
acordar un paquete masivo de sanciones
económicas diseñadas para frenar a la
economía rusa vamos a ver entonces qué
efecto tienen realmente estas sanciones
que para muchos pues no sirven de nada
para otros realmente sí para otros estas
nuevas si son realmente es fuertes para
que pues ya rusia considere lo que está
haciendo en este momento esta incursión
militar en ucrania pero jorge pues todo
lo diré el tiempo pues nadie sabe
solamente pues la élite militar y el
gobierno ruso orden muchísimas gracias
por toda la información económica en
torno a cómo reacciona los mercados de
lo que está pasando en ucrania y pasamos
ahora entonces a saludar a nuestra
segunda mitad del día jorge gracias
[Música]